m'appelle marie andrée guile et
accompagner des premières nations ont
des colonies l'histoire un mot à la fois
école découverte du notre ami au but
avec indian temps très conciliation
aucun talent chômage et voyons ce qu'en
dehors de ça chez nous parfois par
habitude ou par ignorance on peut
utiliser des mots sans savoir qu'ils ont
une connotation pour d'autres cultures
puis qui peuvent être offensants
insultants ou à qui on un sens
complètement différent et c'est pour
décoloniser la langue française qu'un
collectif de jeunes autochtones a décidé
de prendre le bâton de parole et a pondu
un balado aussi utile qu'originale 11
épisodes où on va reconsidérer autant de
noms comme sauvage réserve ou encore
pocahontas et j'en parle avec qui mme
aubry a win cinéaste et productrice au
contenu de ce bal à dos votre balade au
s'intitule laissez nous laisser nous
raconter l'histoire crochet d'abord mal
à mon bon monsieur winch c'est quoi
l'histoire krouchi d'après vous on fait
le compte y est c'est intéressant sans
vis de l'expression anglaise chris drury
et c'est un universitaire anglophone
chercheur qui a pondu ce concept danse
est un concept qui existe pour vrai et
puis bon pour les faits dont nous ont
fait mal à nous en france on a dû
traduire le titre c'est devenu une
histoire krouchi mais c'est cette idée
derrière laquelle ben l'usagé de
certains mots s'est transformée à
décrocher ou fils la colonisation
et puis on se reconnaît plus dans ces
mots là où soit ce sont des mots qui
nous ont dit qu'ils nous ont piqué qui
sont apparues avec la colonisation puis
avec lesquels on se connaît encore moins
j'ai envie de vous lancer sur des
exemples concrets pour que les gens se
fassent une idée de deux mots que vous
allez expliquer expliquer la connotation
de ces mots là il ya le mot aussi banal
que découvert mais c'est pas banal
l'épisode sur la découverte racontez
nous ben non c'est pas banal puis à
priori
on enseigne de moins en moins selon le
mode découverte parce qu'on sait tous
que bon il y avait des autochtones c'est
des amérindiens ou des indiens des
sauvages comme on les appelait qui
épaissit amant moment du débarquement de
christophe colomb pis moi ce que je
trouve vraiment facilement ce que moi
j'ai appris parce que nous aussi comme
autochtone commandes des premiers
peuples on apprend on apprend plein de
choses et puis je savais pas pour penser
c'est québec québec québec c'est un mot
qui aiment racines des pubs de l'ess et
puis ça veut dire débarquer débarquer
débarqué et puis donc c'est ce que
plusieurs intervenants dans le podcast
10 sur cet épisode en particulier de la
découverte
et puis donc on n'a pas découvert on
était la vie puisque l'on a tendu la
main en utilisant à descendre de leur
bateau pour les hindous pour les ok
parce que pour vous comme pour moi même
notre génération on a appris à l'école
dont jacques cartier est arrivé ici eux
mêmes des des plaques à montréal où on
dit jacques cartier pris possession des
terres au nom du roi de france avant ce
que vous dites dans le bas la douce et
n'ont rien découvert on était là
maintenant ce sont en fait on rien
découvert et ont pris possession ceci
est vrai partout oui on était là depuis
depuis au moins quinze mille ans les
archéologues ont prouvé à maintes
reprise il y avait des centaines de
millions d'habitants en amérique du nord
donc on était loin de on est loin d'une
découverte donc comme un des
intervenants dit aussi on peut on peut
dire on est sûr on est allé sur la lune
y avait personne n'a découvert par et
moi aussi dû parler moi aussi du nom
pendant quarante ans après ça va être
amusant personnage popularisé par disney
pourquoi ils choquent certaines femmes
auteures et abusant
c'est drôle parce que sinon ce podcast
ce qu'on propose c'est une diversité de
points de vue dans tout le monde que le
même point de vue sur un mambo dont il y
en a pour qui ces noyaux france il y en
a d'autres qui sait de 15 en france on
parce que nous savons que la violence
faite aux femmes autochtones à faire le
pays est endémique
et puis on avec pau quant à son projet
de l'image d'une femme autochtone pur
comme si on était tous des princesses
amérindiennes ou belles courbes et tout
ça alors que la réalité des femmes
autochtones c'est qu'aux c'est
qu'auparavant on avait un pouvoir c'est
une communauté très important le corps
des femmes étaient sacrés et puis la
colonisation à faire en sorte de
désacraliser ce corps là et puis
aujourd'hui on lit femmes autochtones
sont pas connues mais il peut
plastronner plusieurs reprises qu au
canada donc ça vibre c'est petit c'est
comme un peu hippie dernier comme sujet
chez bien les femmes autochtones que
vous avez raison c'est pas tout le monde
qui est le même point de vue à la balado
eux-mêmes
une femme qui dit ben moi j'aime mieux
pocahontas que barbie personnellement je
m'identifie davantage au personnage de
pocahontas
ils nous réservent aussi pillé plusieurs
allochtone qui peuvent utiliser le mot
réserve on parle la réserve de kahnawake
de 15 ces attaques et qui sont ici en
région de montréal on sait pas quel
point ça peut
c'est un mot c'est un mot qui peut
heurter certains membres des premiers
peuples qui nous bat quand je pense
personnellement au mont réserve y en a
qui en font référence dans l'épisode on
procède réserve faunique presque une
réserve protégée zoologique donc mais
l'idée derrière la création des réserves
c'est un peu ça veut dire en recréer des
réserves des enfants on veut comme pau
claude supprimés entre délimiter
l'espace où les autochtones vont devoir
vivre jusqu'à temps qu'ils ne soient
plus autochtone ont plaidé derrière
c'était c'était de permettre aux
autochtones de s'émanciper puis de
devenir puis de s'assimiler au sein de
la population en général
donc malheureusement ça peut fonctionner
le dessin coloniale n'a pas fonctionné
puis on était encore pris aujourd'hui
avec cette aberration que sont les
réserves
donc et puis aujourd'hui nous on n'aime
pas ce mot là c'est très offensant on
utilise entre nous beaucoup la
communauté conclut que ce serait ma vie
aux gens ok war docteur de quelques de
galles nation de quelques noté tu viens
freinateur d'entrée grand-place
communauté par réserve dans la marine il
nous reste très peu de temps l'émission
mais je veux vous poser la question est
ce que vous pensez que se balade où il
est aussi utile pour les autochtones que
pour les allochtone pense que oui parce
qu'aussi bien au sein même de nos
nations de nos communautés il ya des
dissensions
on a plus souvent l'occasion de se
retrouver autour d'un même table puis je
pense que c'est ce qu'on a fait donc un
balado ou karine et brown ont rencontrés
ont fait plus de 8000 kilomètres et
rencontrer plus de 70 personnes dans 18
communautés puis l'on entend des voix
qu'on entend jamais donc c'est
l'occasion pour nous aussi d'écouter ce
que les autres de plomb à nous raconter
moi j'ai appris une tonne d'affaires ça
fait dix ans que je consacre ma
vieillesse
donc j'espère que c'est vraiment une
main tendue au public allochtone qu'on
lance mais aussi chez nous à nos membres
un bon mais alors votre votre appel est
entendu merci d'avoir